ici citoyenneté c'est une notion avec
l'accord des enfants sont familiarisés
depuis longtemps en classe ces élèves
apprennent les matières traditionnelles
comme tous les autres enfants mais en
plus ils s'intéressent tous les jours à
la solidarité l'entr'aide ou encore
l'écologie
il n'y a pas forcément un cours
magistral au monde et de telle heure à
telle heure on va faire de l'éducation
la citoyenneté
c'est donc comportement quotidien c'est
par exemple le plus grand qui est de le
plus le plus petit c'est dans le fait de
ne pas jeter un papier par terre mais
d'aller mettre à la poubelle c'est
cédant tout un ensemble de gestes très
simples
l'apprentissage à la citoyenneté passe
également par des opérations caritatives
mais aussi le soutien de jeunes réfugiés
croate avec qui les élève correspondent
régulièrement les réponses ça nous avons
crois peut être prêtre
vous nous les apportez une activité qui
suicide chez les enfants des définitions
toute personnelle de ce qu'est
aujourd'hui la citoyenneté
qu'est ce que ça veut dire être un
citoyen aider les autres à faire des
choses puis leur donner des choses
qu'ils ont peur nous correspond avec des
croates et ben comme ils sont trés sont
leurs écrits et puis comme ça ben ils
sont ils sont heureux ici aussi les
parents participent aux activités que le
souhaitent ségolène royal tous les mois
ils sont dans l'informel de l'activité
scolaire grâce un journal édité par
leurs profs aux enfants un cahier de vie
améliorée un ton plus ferme de freiner
fort